[Music]
hello and welcome to how the light gets
in i'm jesse norman and it's my huge
honor and pleasure to be talking now to
esther duflo
whom many of you will know
as
a great economist a great champion of
the relief of poverty around the world
and a
co-winner of the nobel prize
in 2019 so on behalf of the festival on
behalf of all of our viewers esther
thank you so much for joining me and uh
what a pleasure it is to be able to talk
to you thank you so much for having me
and i'm looking forward to this um so so
esther you all appreciate that i'm i'm
going to be talking um not as someone
involved in current politics but as
someone with a background and an
interest in political economy and uh and
and specifically in the work that you do
and
one of the things that i think is so
striking
is the extent to which your work
is
uh an attempt to think
in um
in ways about economics that perhaps
aren't captured in the traditional micro
macro debates and specifically in your
pioneering use of randomized control
trials and i just wonder if we could
start with that just to bring the
audience into your work a little bit and
you could tell us a little bit about how
these trials work give some examples of
as it were great results where things
haven't gone so well and and the like
yes i'll be delighted too so
a lot of our work
is
trying to
start by unpacking the problem of
poverty
as it were which is
you could start by trying to ask a very
bold question which is you know uh does
growth help alleviate poverty or whether
foreign aid works or it does or it hurts
or or somewhere in between
and what you realize when you ask this
type of questions that they are very
difficult to answer because you know how
would you know
uh every country has a different
experience and the growth for example
might come from the tub or it might come
from the bottom with very different uh
impact on the life of the poor and of
course we don't even know what causes
growth in the first place
similarly with aid you know if you look
at africa there was more and more aid uh
over the years and more and more poverty
and the poverty impact were very limited
you might think from just looking at the
gap but of course so many things happen
so maybe it would have been much better
uh without the aid maybe it would have
been much worse without the aid we just
have no idea there is only one world
so we kind of the departure point is
that look that's not these big questions
they're you're not going to get good
answers to them so let's do something
different
potentially maybe
prima facie less ambitious but in fact
more useful
which is to say let's unpack the problem
let's say for example
education is important right everybody
agrees education is important but then
what next like what are you going to
tell for example a developing country
government about the best way to
organize their education system
then it becomes more precise
do you need more teachers
do you need a different curriculum do
you need computers do you need textbooks
so certainly you find yourself with like
thousands of
possible suggestions for how to improve
learning in schools
and there you know we can have
intuitions
but often this is intuitions are not
that good in the sense that often
when things are tried in practice they
don't work exactly the way you planned
so our idea is like look let's treat any
of these suggestions once we have
precise suggestions we can think of them
in the very same way that you think
about a vaccine for covid
which is all we have this great idea
about uh uh um you know using uh a viral
vector or using uh irm messaging well
before we launch it we try it out
so we take a sample take the covet
vaccine trials
you take a sample of about 50 000 people
you give the your candidate vaccine to
half of them randomly selected and to
the other half you don't and then
you wait over time and you see whether
they get infected with covid whether
they get very sick when they get it
hospitalized and whether they die
and
because nothing is different in the two
groups except that some got the vaccine
and some didn't
at the end of the day you can really say
with a lot of confidence that the
vaccine was effective
and it is those trials for the vaccine
that gave us like the huge gift of being
able to combat the epidemic at least in
the rich countries now why not apply the
same type of idea to social programs so
you take the education and say well my
idea is that we need to
abandon a curriculum that is too rigid
and we need to meet every child at their
current level of instruction it's not my
idea it's the idea of an organization
that we met many years ago called
pratham that was my first randomized
control trial we said great let's do
that
so in
we went in two cities bombay and baroda
took a few hundred schools
and in half of those schools they
implemented their program which was
basically a taylor education remedial
education program
for the grade three students
and in half of the school they
implemented the same program for the
grade four students
so now we can compare the great three
students where the program is in place
in grade 3 to the grade 3 student where
the program is in place in grade four
and if we find
the students who benefited from the
program to do better then we know that
it's because the program because nothing
else was different and vice versa was
great for
so we did that and we found
in this particular instance we found the
program to be effective we found that
after one year the kids who benefited
from the program through this chance did
much better
so we could replicate this experiment in
different contexts different places we
figured out that in fact that result was
a very solid
and thanks to that
pratham was able to
scale it up
they are now working with millions and
millions of children in india and today
they
this program has now moved from india to
africa
where it's being implemented again
within in about 20 countries with
various governments reaching millions of
children so that's an example of uh you
know going from the proof of concept to
the evaluation to the scale up
of of a particular intervention
that's great and of course one of the i
mean your book is full of really
interesting examples uh your first book
of cases in particular where this
approach has been taken um mosquito nets
anti-malarials nutrition um it's very
very striking the range of different
contexts um presumably there must be
circumstances in which it doesn't work i
mean in a scientific spirit you get a
new result or even possibly
counterproductive
yes that's why i could tell you with a
lot of confidence that often our
intuitions are not as good as we thought
because having been involved in many
many randomized control trials and being
part of a movement which has been
involved in many
in our lab jpal we now have about 500
researchers that are
affiliated with our movements
and uh
together they have completed you know
over a thousand studies and of this
thousand studies
i would say
at least half
give disappointed disappointing results
uh
that's not a scientific number i haven't
actually calculated but you know more
often than not things don't work as well
as you hoped
uh and some but
the point is that
that's also informative because if you
find that something doesn't work the way
you hope
then
that is giving you guns for example to
not scale it up
or to scale it down
or to
maybe reorient it i'll give you one very
prominent example
which is several years ago we started
evaluating microcredit
which at the time was uh one of the most
successful social innovation in terms of
the number of people it has reached this
is the green bank
about that everyone was talking about
that and of course professor yunus got
the the nobel prize nobel peace prize
for basically the promoting microfinance
and and disseminating it
but there had not been an evaluation of
its impact
so we didn't know there was a lot of
hope that it would be extremely
effective at uh alleviating poverty it
was very successful in terms of being
popular and reaching a lot of people but
there was no evaluation
and then
about a half dozen evaluations around
the world started springing up from
different research projects
and what was really striking is that in
none of this evaluation
the researchers found a sig any
difference really between the treatment
group that was exposed to microfinance
and the control group so that was a huge
surprise to the researchers and i think
if you had only one study you would not
believe it you would say well maybe the
study was wrong or something but when
you have half a dozen
together that really changed the
conversation
and at the beginning the microfinance
organization were of course very
disappointing bit disappointed and they
resisted a little bit the news
but then what happened is that that also
prompted a rethinking of
how they should think about their
mission and how it should organize their
mission so it becomes projective in
since we are not saying that
the fundamental problem that
microfinance is trying to address which
is
the poor don't have access to credit is
still there
uh the the question is how do we design
a solution that is actually effective
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas